[Musique]
nous sommes le jeudi 22 décembre 2016
bonsoir et bienvenue pour cette nouvelle
édition du 7 suite les invités émission
dédiée vous le savez maintenant à celles
et ceux qui font l'actualité dans le
département et aujourd'hui vous
entendrez kevin lee a green est c'est un
livre i noël et cofondateur de la
société yugo chasse est une plateforme
qui permet à des experts de tester les
systèmes informatiques d'entreprises
soucieuses de se protéger contre les
attaques en d'autres termes pour les non
initiés c'est un gentil hacker bonsoir
abandonne instant leur rappeur ali et
deux colombiens diouf je vais y arriver
aux usa l'idiot elle lui aussi utilisent
l'outil internet et va bientôt lancer un
rendez vous en ligne pour faire
connaître les artistes locaux et puis
parallèlement il peaufine aussi la
sortie de son prochain album
bonsoir et bienvenue puis mon fin
d'édition nouveau entendrons nous
retrouverons à versailles lors
guillaumet et écuyers à l'académie et
castrats nationale elle participe à un
spectacle la voie de l'écuyer qui est
actuellement représentation on va donc
commencer avec vous kevin vous êtes
yvelinois versailles les cofondateurs de
yugo chat en japonais cela signifie
défense gentils pirates de
l'informatique comme ça qu'on présente
simplement votre activité
c'est quoi un gentil pirate un gentil
hacker comme un gentil pirate un gentil
pirate c'est un acteur qui va aider les
entreprises à sécuriser tout simplement
qui va pas chercher des failles pour les
revendre sur le marché noir mais qui va
plutôt chercher des failles dans le but
d'aider l'entreprise à les colmater de
façon discrète et de façon à ce que les
informations des utilisateurs ne soient
pas diffusées publiquement de façon à ce
qu un site ne tombe pas parce qu'il a
été attaqué au genre de choses
donc c'est la même démarche qu'à kanaker
mais c'est pas la même finalité tout à
fait aider ces entreprises le concept à
qui a inspiré cette start up c'est le
bug bounty ça vient des états unis tout
à fait ça se résume le bug bounty alors
le boys band 6 si vous voulez c'est une
entreprise qui va déposer une mission
sur une plate forme durant laquelle
flotte se fera sur laquelle elle va
demander à des hackers de chercher des
vulnérabilités et pour chaque
vulnérabilité remonter en fait
l'entreprise va rémunérer le hacker si
vous voulez contrairement à ce qui
existe aujourd'hui on passe d'une
obligation de moi
d'habitude d'entreprise pour sécuriser
fait appel à des prestations de service
durant laquelle plusieurs personnes sur
une durée déterminée vont audités le
système d'information et aujourd'hui on
passe sur une obligation de résultats où
l'entreprise ne paye que lorsqu'il ya du
résultat c'est à dire une faille
véridique qui impacte vraiment systèmes
d'information c'était donc les
entreprises vous sollicite elles font
tester leur site soit par toute la
communauté soit ce sont certains hackers
il ya des profils qui sont sélectionnés
pour essayer de faire tomber justement
le site c'est comme ça que ça fonctionne
je sollicite et puis tout à fait sûr
youcha en fait c'est une communauté
fermée sont des gens qu'on va chercher
on va chercher la crème de la crème dans
le monde du hacking ces gens qu'on
connaît
cc c'est la promesse qu'on fait en fait
aux entreprises
on a fait le choix d'être une plateforme
fermée de façon à leur garantir une
vraie qualité éviter le bruit c'est à
dire des rapports qui sont des faux
positifs qui ne sont pas réellement des
failles et plutôt essayer de leur
apporter une vraie plus value sur ce que
sur ce que leur rapportent les hackers
comment on démarche cca coeur bien
intentionnés justement eybens comment
dire d'abord vous le promets certes
c'est à dire les gens et qu'ils aient
toujours travaillé que vous connaissez
qui vont pouvoir vous recommander aussi
des gens là qu'ils ont eux-mêmes travail
et les résultats petit par effet boule
de neige
il ya des gens qui vont s'interroger sur
sept plateaux sur cette plateforme
fermée se demander finalement jsk et sur
cette plateforme est ce que moi j'ai pas
les compétences pour le faire et qu'ils
vont tout simplement de solliciter ça
peut faire peur aux entreprises c'est ce
que vous me disais quand on prépare un
petit peu cet entretien vous avez lancé
votre entreprise bah octobre 2015 et au
début il a fallu convaincre ces
entreprises parce que lorsqu'on explique
qu'on va soumettre son serveur ses
systèmes informatiques à des hackers ça
peut effrayer forcément tout à fait en
fait le terme hacker a est connoté
cybercriminels depuis un long moment là
petit à petit les entreprises se rendent
compte que la sécurité il faut la
prendre au sérieux et on arrive petit à
petit leur faire comprendre que le
hacker finalement c'est justin cherche
un chercheur en sécurité
c'est parfois quelqu'un qui travaille
déjà en cdi dans une précédente dans une
société de services et qui fait lui-même
des audits aussi toute la journée c'est
parfois juste des passionnés
d'informatique qui n'ont pas ce qu'ils
ont petit kienan qui n'arrivent pas à
qui n'ont pas de diplôme mais qui ont
cette capacité à trouver des failles
pour les prix sans surprise il ya une
psychose aujourd'hui des entreprises
parce qu'on voit des grands groupes
comme on peut citer apple sony qui sont
piratés aussi qui des fois son face à de
la cyber criminalité
il ya une psychose des entreprises
aujourd'hui parce que maintenant que
vous avez fini de leur expliquer que
c'était plutôt positif
les entreprises se ruent vers vous pour
leur donner un petit coup de main alors
et puis ça petit en fait on se rend
compte que les entreprises ont vraiment
du mal à recruter en fait ce genre de
profil et donc je vois le boys band si
comme une approche complémentaire des
audits des zones de sécurité habituelles
et donc c'est pas on veut pas dire
qu'une psychose mais en fait il faut
savoir c'est que à partir de 2017
il ya un une deux une colle à la
commission européenne a décidé que les
entreprises seraient pénalisés à hauteur
de 4% de leur chiffre d'affaires
si jamais les données des utilisateurs
fuite et si jamais il y avait une
attaque parce qu'elle est la leur et ses
salars est important pour l'entreprise
d'avoir toutes les données maintenant
puisque toutes nos données sont en ligne
c'est de voir ces données partir est de
plus en plus avec l'intérêt des objets
qui commence à voir communiquer tout un
tas d'objets non sécurisés où il ya de
l'information qui transitent on continue
parce que maintenant tout et tout passe
par les réseaux que ce soit le simple
volet où les voitures et il le simple
volet roulant il faut que toute voix
soit sécurisé effectivement alors votre
projet a séduit les membres du jury des
grands prix de l'innovation de la ville
de paris vous avez reçu donc ce prix
aujourd'hui ça permet de faire un bon
pour votre entreprise où on est les
développements oui je veux en fait ce
prix donne une vraie visibilité c'est
aussi la concrétisation de tout cette
année qu'on a passée à évangéliser on se
rend compte que va en effet finalement
le service qu'on propose il a du sens
ils trouvent preneurs et ça va nous
permettre de convaincre des grands
groupes qui peut-être à se demander qui
étaient ces gens un petit peu outsider
qui n'était pas finalement dans la
sécurité au départ certes ya certes un
des associés qui était de ce milieu là
mais on apparaît vraiment comme des gens
qui sortaient de nulle part et ça
cette reconnaissance là c'est ce qu'il
nous permette d'aller voir ces grands
groupes et aujourd'hui pour le
développement vous faites une levée de
fonds oui tout à fait on est en train de
lever des fonds là on discute avec des
des vies si on est sur une levée de
fonds de tutsis donc ça va être entre
300 et 700 kg à environ n'a pas le on a
pas les chiffres exacts
ah oui tout à fait c'est si on devrait
en savoir plus sur cet axe ses activités
le nom du site internet ans est affiché
vous pouvez connaître un petit peu plus
et pourquoi pas participer à cette levée
de fonds rejoindre ce groupe de gentils
hackers voilà résumée comme sa mère si
vous restez avec nous sur le plateau on
reste dans ce domaine un petit peu
d'internet encore avec ali deuce j'ai
bien prononcé cette fois ci l'artiste
rappeur alors que c'est via internet que
vous souhaitez vous faire connaître déjà
vous mais aussi faire connaître d'autres
artistes vous avez un projet sans
réflexion mettre en place un site
internet pour médiatiser un peu les les
rappeurs locaux pourquoi ça aujourd'hui
on a l'impression que c'est de
démocratiser
parce que en fait je trouve que les clés
les médias
connu en fait s'intéressent uniquement
aux rappeurs ou alors aux artistes déjà
connus ou alors qu'ils connaissent
d'autres gens pour filon en fait alors
moi ce que je voudrais c'est vraiment
donner la chance à tous ceux qui qu'il
souhaite en fait compte du talent parce
qu'elle me coûte allemands qui sont pas
exploitées donc j'estime que tout le
monde a droit à sa chance donc ce projet
c'est pour donner la chance à chacun de
pouvoir s'exprimer
comment de son département des yvelines
et est riche justement directement à
jean baptiste et qui sont méconnus juste
dans le secteur dans tout ce qui est rap
guyancourt montini tout ça il ya
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de monde et
dans dans d'autres villes aussi parce
que je connais pas mal de rappeurs
d'artistes de beatmaker de dj dans paris
d'un à toulouse à bordeaux j'ai pas mal
de connexion donc ben je voudrais en
profiter pour faire un un petit peu de
buzz pour tout le monde quand il se sera
alors comment ça se passe en ce moment
vous réfléchissez autour de ce projet en
fait lâché en train de mettre tout ça en
place
je vais commencer bientôt aller filmer
les artistes en fait le truc c'est que
je vais j'ai des contacts déjà et je
vais aller les voir en fait directement
dans leur quartier ou alors dans l'eure
dans leur studio
peu importe enfin dans leur
environnement ce qu'ils habitent dans
leur milieu et je vais les interroger
par rapport à leurs projets ce qu'ils
ont déjà sorti leurs projets futurs ce
qui va arriver et je veux leur demander
de nous faire un petit show en live et
voilà ça sera diffusée sur ce sera
l'occasion de connaître tout ça
j'imagine que c'est un univers qui vous
parle parce que je crois savoir vous
étiez dans ce aussi on aurait pu aussi
évoquer ce sujet là aujourd'hui sur le
plateau
voici vous souhaitez vous faire
connaître vous avez 28 ans vous êtes de
bois d'arcy rappeur vous préparer la
sortie de ce street cd on va le montrer
qui est déjà sorti en fait c'est raté
fait montre à la caméra
voilà alors en fait c'est sorti le 11
septembre 2016 je les enregistrais dans
le sud ont enregistré ici je
l'enregistrais avec
mais sur deux bouts en el hachmi à qui
passe le bonjour d'ailleurs qui m'a
beaucoup aidé et qui a toujours été là
qui sera toujours là d'ailleurs
et le prochain match est venu pour
présenter cd et là il ya un maxi de six
titres qui va sortir en avril ou en mai
début mais j'ai pas encore la date
exacte mais ça va arriver et l'album qui
sortira ni 20 en hiver 2007 on écoute un
petit extrait justement parce qu'on peut
aussi retrouver ces différents morceaux
sur internet sur youtube notamment
autant petit extrait ok j'ai la recette
trajet mais ne rompt pas les consommer
mais j'espère j'ai pu mais quand
j'appelle ça opprimés et pour lui
j'arrêterais l'album la droite moment
beaucoup de temps est passé j'en ai
perdu des bons moments
j'ai commis j'arrêterai pas d'aller à
l'école j'ai zappé touche déconne je
vais changer les taux courts très
enlevée tue pas vraiment
quelque chose les années sont passées
j'ai pris le chemin qu'on nous propose
sa mort ce qu'on vient d'entendre ses
promesses promesses quels sont les
thèmes aussi vous souhaitez un petit peu
abordé vous à travers votre musique aux
textes déjà la vie de tous les jours la
vie que j'ai vu qu auparavant
parce que il ya assez de monde c'est
différent on a évolué en a on a mûri il
ya plein plein plein de choses dont je
voudrais parler justement ces cibles
d'en savoir plus je vous invite à vous
invite à le télécharger sur votre
culture c'est gratuit pas de problème
est dû au sort dire ça on retrouve ça
effectivement sur sur internet avant
vous étiez en groupe aujourd'hui en solo
oui exactement pasqua
ben c'était frustrant non c'était bien
mais c'était on était jeunes et on
n'avait pas comprenais pas ça au sérieux
et puis des années sont passées puis au
final comme tout le monde chacun reprend
sa route quoi en fait et puis ben on est
j'ai envie de dire on n'est jamais mieux
servi que par soi même n aujourd'hui
c'est ce lait dans ce livre aussi parce
que vous travaillez un gros c est dans
une petite activité si forcément à côté
le belize et d'en vivre
est-ce que vous avez le temps de faire
des scènes aussi j'ai fait une scène
justement là le 10 novembre qui est
passé à la salle de la torah voisins
bretons lieu j'ai été invité par un ami
à moi en slam on verra qui est qui fait
partie d'une association qui justement
la femme de 50 ans de saint quentin en
yvelines
parce que moi aussi mon invité avec pas
mal d'artistes c'était c'était cool il y
aura des scènes il ya une scène qui se
prépare la sentir je sais pas j'ai pas
la date exacte ne se sera en mars ou en
vous viendrez nous en parler alors voilà
continuer d'apprendre avocat elle
remplit avec la somalie d'où son album
qui est déjà disponible au moins sur
internet voilà en tout cas vous pouvez
vous procurer ensuite le street cd
l'album tout ça est en projet merci
aussi kevin garde est revenu ça pour les
explications de soucht cette entreprise
yugo chat lauréats des grands prix
d'innovation de la ville de paris merci
à vous et pour continuer ce 7,8 les
invités nous partons à présent pour
versailles peut-être allez-vous profiter
des vacances de noël pour visiter
l'académie équestre national de
représentation du spectacle la voie de
l'écuyer sont encore programmés avant la
fermeture hivernale de l'établissement
on écoute lors guillaume c'est une
aiguille et est titulaire elle nous en
dit plus le spectacle la voie de
l'écuyer
un spectacle de répertoire ce qu'on
appelle un spectacle de répertoire c'est
notre spectacle est le même depuis
quasiment l'ouverture de l'académie donc
le même pas tout à fait c'est un
spectacle qui évolue avec le temps avec
les chevaux les cavaliers les
disciplines artistiques divers et variés
que nous pratiquons donc on
l'agrémentent de au fil des années de
chant de danse d'escrimé artistique etc
et donc il évolue avec le temps et c'est
vraiment le reflet de ce qu'on vit à
l'académie c'est une académie où on a
une formation artistique en dansant
champ
en escrime artistique en cube d'eau et
donc ses voiles à développer tous les
arts et les mettre ensuite au service du
spectacle au service de l'émotion et la
technique à cheval quand on parle du
cheval centaure entre guillemets c'est
vraiment que quand quelqu'un nous
regarde là vous avez vu le spectacle ne
s'est pas de se dire oh ce cavalier au
cheval c'est de se dire rien du tout
juste une harmonie d'un couplet
et voilà
l'osmose du couple est vraiment
important un peu comme vous voyez des
danseurs danser en couple voilà c'est
l'émotion qui se dégage d'un balai et
c'est un peu ce qu'on cherche ici rend
tout chose c'est la fin de cette 8è les
invités pour ce soir prochain rendez
vous le 2 janvier d'ici là je vous
souhaite bien évidemment d'excellentes
fêtes de fin d'année très bon noël très
bon réveillon du nouvel an également
tout cela au nom des équipes de tv fil
78 qui auront plaisir à vous retrouver
pour 2010 est très bonne soirée très
bonnes vacances sur notre antenne
[Musique]